Speaker 1: You know, one of the things about
a cult is that the cult leader will expect,
if not demand absolute and total sacrifice and
loyalty from the cult followers. And failed
Arizona Republican gubernatorial candidate
Carrie Lake is doing exactly that. She wants
supporters who are willing to go to jail for
her. The delusions of grandeur are getting worse
and worse for Carrie Lake. Here she is saying
these. Listen, you should be willing to go and
sit in jail for the movement or whatever,
but really she means for her. Check this.
Speaker 3: Out. I wish that somebody would
say, you know what? Arrest me then. I don't
care. We need people with courage to
say class. What felony? Go ahead. Go
for it. Arrest me. Because this is a botched
election and you're disenfranchizing tell.
Speaker 1: Me it's a felony to be out here doing
what I'm doing and arrest me because Carrie
Lake really won even though she didn't.
Speaker 3: The folks in Mojave County,
when you allow this kind of an
election in Maricopa County to stand.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I like this clip because it
confirms very openly and clearly what we've
suspected for a long time, which is that this
is a cult. You're willing to go to jail for me,
right? Because I'm that important to you. Has she
offered them a pardon on state charges when she's
installed as governor as Donald Trump demanded
that she be on troth central in the middle of
the night earlier this week? Like, if she's
really that confident she's ultimately going
to overturn this, why not make that offer?
When I finally ascend to the governorship,
I'm going to pardon every single one of you, truly
a person with not a single redeeming quality about
her. Carrie Lake. She also, by the way, did the
globalist thing and it's so tired at this point,
but here she pulls that out as well,
saying it's bigger than her, that in this,
this is another cult thing. Even though I need
you to go to jail, for me, it's really bigger
than me. In this case, it's about the globalists.
Speaker 3: We feel very competent in our case,
and I have not given up one scintilla of the
fight I have in me. Somebody said, Carrie,
you're fearless. And I said, You know, I guess
I'm fearless right now in this difficult time,
because what I fear most of all is what happens
if we don't step forward and act with courage
right now, what we're left with, we will have a
shell of our country. We look at what's happening
in Brazil and what's happening in China will be
looking a lot like China. And I'm not talking
about the protests happening now. I'm talking
about we'll be enslaved by globalist system if
we don't stand up right now. This is our moment.
This is our true moment right now in our history.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that if you went to
Carrie Lake and said, what exactly do you mean
by globalism and what are the parameters of the
globalist system? She probably couldn't answer.
Maybe she'd come up with some passing thing,
but she wouldn't be able to really answer.
If you go to Carrie Lake supporters and
many of them are Trump supporters as well,
and you ask them what is globalism, what do you
what do you mean by when you talk about globalism
and globalists? If you're lucky, they'll be able
to rattle off the names of a few Jewish men,
but they are not even understanding what it is
that is being fed to them. So reminder, Carrie
Lake didn't. When Carrie Lake will not be the
governor of Arizona, don't send her any money if
you want it, you know, fool. And their money are
soon parted. It's all a scam. She's. She didn't
win. And she's not going to be the governor.
But now she's saying this is about fighting
globalists and you should be willing to go to
jail. For me, it is a cult. Ladies and gentlemen,